for me one of the best parts about kind
of growing with this culture has been to
always stay true to the ideals that it
first started we're not here to trying
to convince people of what it is we're
here to offer you these facts that you
have not been presented before you
haven't even seen the evidence you're
basing your opinion on what you've been
shown but not everything else I think
it's hard to divorce people from their
politics Kev it is man because it's the
politics is not just politics it's their
entire circle of friends the echo
chamber that comes with the family that
they're with it's who you follow on
Instagram telling the algorithms telling
people to leave your family yeah it's
crazy so people have gotten to a point
where it doesn't matter the morality of
the person that's been assigned to it as
long as it's their side they can find a
reason to not hold that person to the
same standards as they would somebody
else and at that point it's just so
politicized that there's no moral left
in it it's not like there's a moral
compass there's just like oh okay
imagine if your lawyer your your son
goes to to trial for murder right right
the best lawyer in the world
has a 14 year old wife and you're like
dude he's the best lawyer in the world
though right what are we doing here
that's where we are in politics and you
know we don't even have a shared history
you saw the governor of Florida get up
and say hey it's wrong
we have stolen land right yeah it's
great I was going to ask you man because
we're probably it's funny because I
remember as a kid how much people did
not [ __ ] with George W bush at a certain
point I remember like that Michael Moore
[ __ ] came out uh I forget that it was a
bowling 911 or some [ __ ] uh that the the
first documentary that kind of like
was that kind of political people
weren't [ __ ] with bush but then there
was people who were loving Bush but
now man this [ __ ] is so crazily divided
and I feel like the pendulum on each
side has swung
so
extreme that like if somebody like you
said if somebody is just a a normal
Common Sense human being like you said
like I feel like I probably I grew up
like a Democrat right but I feel like
more and more I'm just like maybe I'm
just like an independent or uh a
Libertarian I don't know because like
you said I'm also very pro-second
Amendment um but nowadays man it's like
everybody and it's probably always been
like this but it's a little bit more
magnified these days because of social
media but I just feel like we're in this
like weird rut as a country where like
everybody is just so standing on
whatever this island is and whatever
this Island's going for at the time you
have to align with all of it or you're
on you're over there like I would like I
would have the truth is it you bring up
a good point Democrats have never fought
against Republicans as hard as they
fought against the left wing of their
own party that's the god that's the
God's honest truth and a lot of people
that I personally know that started
getting closer to trumpism and to Maga
and I I you listen this is the god
listen if you if your feelings get hurt
I I'm not here to coddle you a lot of
those people were actually Bernie
Sanders supporters
and they feel and they feel that the
Democratic party is more corrupt than
the Republicans Bernie over two two
times but they they feel like it's more
corrupt I think when we talk about the
war being involved in it that's one
thing where I have to draw a line
because Republicans can't hide behind
Trump's skirt simply because he didn't
start any new Wars he dropped a MOAB on
Afghanistan and after the first 18
months of his presidency please look it
up the drone strikes started again
however that doesn't excuse them pushing
Democrats to a point where they had to
have Mr Obama commit a series of war
crimes because the drone strikes that he
was uh sending out to Afghanistan were
based on metadata that's why they gave
him the name the Drone Ranger right
because those metadatas the metadata
literally means a phone or a device so
you're basing it on a phone that this
person right which is why when they
exposed the rate of the drone strikes
they found out that it was over 80 and
90 percent the wrong person that they
hid and why did we have to learn that
through Wikileaks that's just unfair to
the people themselves who pay taxes into
a system where they believed they were
actually fighting a war against people
trying to kill us whereas we knocked
over a country that had nothing to do
with 9 11. nothing and then when we get
really into detail remember the the that
lady Sarah Palin and everybody was
making fun of her because she couldn't
answer what the Bush Doctrine was listen
the Bush Doctrine ladies and gentlemen
is US knocking over countries in the
Middle East that don't follow our
hegemonic view of the region tell me
that Mr Obama didn't do that once Mr
Bush got out of office he did the same
thing that's the issue that we're facing
we're facing the nakedness of the Empire
The Mask taken off the revealing of the
fact that we don't actually care if a
place is democratic or communist or any
of these things as long as you back the
United States of America will give you a
pass in the same way that I see these
horrible things that the arguments that
are happening online in between uh black
people and Jewish people over what's
transpired Kanye and everything and I
say the sad part is that if you look at
actual conservatives that have said
horrible things about Jewish people
they're not they're better they're not
touched but it's also because they
supported the state of Israel in the
same sentence so this complicates the
case very much and I think it's actually
damaged the relationship that black and
Jewish people have because they feel
like they've been singled out and the
other group feels like they've been
singled out I think that more than ever
needs some kind of healing some kind of
reciprocity to understand because you
have an entire group of people who say
well there's different consequences for
US versus that and that makes people
feel like their lives aren't worth the
same right right and I think on the
other end you have a group of people who
have felt that they've been persecuted
in Europe and now they're persecuted
here and therefore high up on end and
whether you agree with anything the man
said or not you have legitimate divide
in the community now where people are
arguing that didn't even have a problem
Consciousness to argue before so like
you said the political lines are already
kind of drawn there for a person if they
wanted to crawl into that trench to then
feel comfortable with because they don't
have to listen to an opposing opinion
like you said there's a lot of echo
Chambers there's a lot of places where
people just hear something repeated they
don't want to hear the truth they don't
want to say okay well Republicans have
actually never shrunken the size of
government that Democrats have committed
war crimes in the past two two decades
these are not comfortable topics but
they're true and that's the reason why I
guess people love my music because I
give it to both sides because I don't
pull punches and because when it comes
down to it I'm not just independent in
terms of the music but I try to be
independent here in front of the
politics because I realize what's
actually happened as a case of this now
we could take subject matters
independently right like immigration
abortion and we can discuss all these
things of course but with that comes
historical Nuance right when people say
oh immigrants who got everything and I'm
like well why don't you look up the
Homestead Act or the Dawes Act where
this government gave millions of acres
to White settlers that just came off a
boat from somewhere because you wanted
indigenous people to be replaced we hear
a lot from the far right about a white
replacement Theory but let's have a
conversation about indigenous
replacement practice
cultural reality of that yeah so I think
in many ways it's not that people are
angry at socialism Kev they're mad that
only rich people have been able to use
it that they got billions of dollars of
bailouts and that nobody who lost their
home gun you always say like socialism
like obviously I think like I was a
Bernie supporter I donated to this
campaign I loved Bernie I just loved him
because he was the most consistent
politician I had ever seen at least it
was very honest in the sense that you
know when you heard that Hillary Clinton
calling him a violent misogynist
everyone was scratching their head like
you talk about your husband you talk
about Bernie she's wild what are we
doing here she's